according to string theory if there are
about 11 dimensions rather than the four
that we know I was just wondering
whether that of the missing seven the
chances are high or low that at least
one of them will be another one of time
or is time just a unique dimension so
you ask could there be extra time
dimensions could some of the extra
space-time dimensions that say string
theory often suggests B time like that's
a very interesting question time is one
of the most mysterious aspects of of our
theoretical framework and you know the
first person I know that wrote a
interesting paper about the possibility
of extra time dimensions was Andre
Sakharov this was before string theory
but extra dimensions go back the Kaluza
and Klein in the 1920s and but everyone
has thought about this including Zeca
runs into problems if you time is very
different although unified with space
very different than space as you know in
in ordinary space you can go around in a
circle and come back to the same point
time is there's only one time dimension
so far and we can only go in one
direction in time now imagine we had two
times two time coordinates and time
would be sort of like a plane and you
could move in time in a circle and come
back to the same point the same instant
and once you start imagining coming back
the same instant in time you get into
all sorts of problems much like you have
when you contemplate time travel where
you can move back in time and then just
sit there until this instant
is so I could come back if I could time
travel to this very instant in space and
time that gives rise to all sorts of
causality paradoxes you could go back
and kill your grandmother and then you
wouldn't exist and so on and so all
attempts so far to incorporate extra
time coordinates and consider a
space-time with more than one time have
led to various types of inconsistencies
or contradictions breakdown of causality
it's not that people haven't tried they
have tried on normally they try to get
rid of or explain away the extra time
dimensions and show how they're not
observable thereby avoiding some of
these contradictions but they haven't
truly been successful so I don't really
know the answer to your question there
might very well be a framework in which
there are more dimensions of time after
all there are lots of dimensions of
space there might be a framework in
which both space and time
are emergent concepts in which case the
number of dimensions of time by itself
being an emergent concept but we just
don't know it's a it's a lot of fun to
speculate about such things but so far
nobody has been able to conceive of a
sensible way of describing physical
reality without a unique time